[موسيقى]
الطائرات المسيره عنوان المرحله في حرب
روسيا على اوكرانيا العاصمه الروسيه للمره
الثانيه منذ بدء الحرب على اوكرانيا عرضه
لهجوم بطائرات مسيره وصفته روسيا
بالارهابي متهمه كييف بالوقوف وراءه هي
تمني طائره مسيره وفق وزاره الدفاع
الروسيه اسقطت خمس منها في مقاطعه موسكو
بمنظومه فانسيا
باستخدام معدات الحرب الالكترونيه بينما
تعرضت مباني سكنيه في اطراف موسكو اضرار
طفيفه لكن موقع سفيزدا التابعه لوزاره
الدفاع الروسيه اشار الى نحو 32 مسيره
شاركت في الهجوم على موسكو اما موقع ريبار
العسكريه الروسي فقال ان مسيرات يوجي 22
الاوكرانيه وهي قادره على التحليق لنحو
800 كيلومتر رصدت سابقا في مناطق قريبه من
موسكو استهداف موسكو بالمسيرات يعقوب
بساعات هجوما روسيا واسعا بطائره مسيره
على العاصمه
ساعه ولكن ايضا بعشره صواريخ من نوع
اسكندر الباليستيه بعيده المدى واسقطت وفق
روايه الاوكرانيه الرئيس الروسي قال انما
سماه هجوم المسيره الاوكراني على موسكو
جاء ردا على ضربه روسيه استهدفت قياده
الاستخبارات العسكريه الاوكرانيه وفي حين
تقول كيف انها غير مسؤوله عن اي هجمات
داخل روسيا بدل لافتا نفي مستشار الرئاسه
الاوكرانيه اي علاقه مباشره بالهجوم
الاخير دخان التصعيد بدا جليا في الاشهر
الاخيره الهجوم هو الثاني خلال هذا الشهر
على موسكو حيث استهدفت بدايه الشهر
مسيرتان مقره كريميلين دون اصابات ومنذ
ذلك الحين اخذت الهجمه في العمق الروسي
وتيره متصاعده رغم النفي الاوكراني
المتكرر لمسؤوليتها على الجبهه الشرقيه
القصف المدفعي الاوكراني ينال مقاطعه بشكل
شبهي وقبل نحو اسبوع في هجوم غير مسبوق
مجموعه عسكريه وصفتهم موسكو بالقوميين
الاوكرانيين في المقاطعه باستخدام معدات
عسكريه غربيه السنه اعقب ذلك تعرض السفينه
الحربيه الروسيه لمقاله موسكو انه هجوم
فاشل من قبل ثلاثه زوارق مسيره اوكرانيه
في البحر الاسود عند اقتراب السفينه
بالمضيق البسفور وبعد ذلك بيوم اتهم جهاز
امن الدوله الروسي من وصفهم بالخاربين
الاوكرانيين بمحاوله التقريب محطتين
نوويتين
ملاغمتين محطه لتكرير النفط في منطقه
بسكوب الروسيه وتمد خط ركبه ضخم الذي ينقل
النفط الخامس سيبيريا الى اوروبا على بعد
نحو 600 كم من الحدود مع اوكرانيا مؤشرات
متعدده تشيب تحول في مسار الحرب بعد ان
تردد كثيرا حديث عن هجوم اوكراني مضاد وهو
ما يطرح تساؤلات بشان حجم وطبيعه رد الفعل
الروسي وتعامل الغرب مع هذه التطورات